والحديث عن خير الامثله عن كرم اهالي
البصره تنضم الينا من هناك مراسله صباح
العربيه زينب المشاط زينب اهلا بك وباهل
الكرام
صباح الخير سهام وتحيه طبعا ينادين همم
سهام طبعا
اليوم القصه هي راح تكون جانب بسيط من
الكرم العراقي المعروف يعني وخاصه كرم اهل
البصره كرم اهل البصره الكبير جدا جدا
مصطفى يعني شاب متوسط العيش ويستخدم
سيارته الخاصه اللي يعمل عليها كسائق اجره
همم استخدمها
بمبادرته خلال همم
بطوله خليجي 25 مبادره لاطلاقها هذه
المبادره اللي اطلقها واللي يفكر بها
بالتزامن معه همم انطلاقه البطوله اللي
حاول من خلالها ان يعكس صوره جميله عن
العراق وبنفس الوقت يقدم خدمات بسيطه
للضيوف اللي قادمين طبعا انا افضل ان هو
مصطفى هو يتحدثين اكثر عن هذه المبادره
تفضل مصطفى صباح الخير
مصطفى همم يعني شلون سكرت هذه المبادره
واش معنى اختاريت سيارتك الخاصه لاطلاق
هذه المبادره
بالمنصب الاعلامي يسحب المنصبه مثلا
محافظه
اسوي شعر على سيارتي لا تطلب تاكسي طال
عمرك سيارتي تحت امرك حتى الناس تشوفها
ذاك اليوم من احد الصدف وانا نسيتهم
المدينه الرياضيه
شافني شخص عماني يصور السياره
نشرها على تويتر
طمني شنو الاوضاع قلت لهم تعالوا وكل شيء
موجود لا تفكرون لابسه اكل لا بناكل لا
باي شيء
فتواصل لمده اربع ايام ضبط اموره
[موسيقى]
على تويتر
ما يهمني يعني شخص معروف قد ما تمني نجاح
البطوله بقد ما تهمني رضا الناس الي
والوفود اللي قادمه للباصره اللي جاي يشوف
هذا الشيء حلو جميل
اشخاص خليجين يجون يصورون يم السياره
يشوفون نقله وصوره ثانيه عن البصره وعن
العراق وعن كرم الضيافه هذا اللي يسعدني
الاماكن اللي اخذت بها ضيوفك
رحنا المقبره الانجليز نحنا ايضا عندنا
مخبز قديم اسمه مخبز ابو ايمان باداره
مصطفى ايضا رحنا لهذا المخبز فوق او الخبز
العراقي
اهلا طيب شكرا لك